هذه الصور كما تشاهدون الان على اوائل
العربيه هي من بلده عزمارين في ريف حلب
وحلب هي من المدن التي تاثرت بشكل كبير
جراء هذا الزلزال اذا هذه لقطات لاثار
الدمار في هذه البلده بلده كما نتابع
وكانها تعرضت
للقصف المباني مقدمه بشكل كامل ولا نعلم
ما اذا كان هناك اشخاص محاصرين تحت
الانقاذ ولكن على ما يبدو بان هناك اشخاص
يبحثون عن ناجين جراء
هذا الدمار الذي لحق بتلك المبانه
هذه الصور شاهدناها وشاهدنا صور مماثله
لها سواء في المناطق السوريه او حتى
المناطق التركيه اثار الدمار واسعه وبشكل
كبير
بانتظار وصول المساعدات الدوليه التي وعدت
بها اكثر من دوله في محاوله لانقاذ او
العثور على المزيد من الناجين من هذا
الدمار الهائل الذي لحق بعدد من البلدات
التركيه والسوريه